what's happened you bad [ __ ]
it's Wednesday June 24th get your [ __ ]
together greetings from podcast Ville
take this [ __ ] me Lee
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
beautiful fantasy alive [ __ ]
it's Wednesday the 24th I have a guest
but first I want to talk to you happy
Father's Day whenever with all this
[ __ ] stupidity we didn't get a chance
to talk about Father's Day I hope all
the dads had a good time and the kids
and the whole [ __ ] thing everything
is great we're back to normal we didn't
dodged a bullet there was no bullet to
dodge there was nothing there so thank
you for having my back loyal
[ __ ] you know from day one I've
been talking about loyalty and you guys
proved it you guys got the message how
it works that could have bad you got to
stick together if not you have nothing
you have no reason to have friends the
people that do this type of [ __ ] they're
the people that watched friends and
thought the world is [ __ ] just you
know so having to go [ __ ] themselves
beside that I'm beautiful I feel good
the flying [ __ ] Jew we did a couple
edibles yesterday I hope you enjoyed the
livestream you know I'm saying we're
gonna do a couple more those wanted dead
or alive I like that I like that right
off the bat represent and I'm smoking
some [ __ ] cherry gas from urban trees
and I'm just feeling good
had a great Father's Day I'd say a quick
story and then we'll bring in Russell my
Adam Timmy Holloway is a dear friend of
mine listener family he sent me a Jimmy
Page model he sent me a Pistol Pete one
and a Julius Erving one this is was this
was his private stock and he sent them
to me so I appreciate them very much
Hannah and Ozzy Osbourne and I had them
all here in the office and little by
little every time my daughter comes to
the [ __ ] office she takes one like
all of a sudden she's a fan of [ __ ]
Ozzy Osbourne she liked it cuz he had a
bat little did she know that
[ __ ] got whoo and I took that
bat away right so she took that one home
then she came in another time and took
the [ __ ] julius erving home which I
had at home anyway she wanted to claim
it but I taught it stays at the [ __ ]
on this table she was alright with it
then a few weeks ago she comes in here
and she takes the [ __ ] Jimmy Page one
it's because he has the double neck
guitar and [ __ ]
with the strap and she went home and
started listening to Led Zeppelin
believe it or not
I caught her watching the Sun in May is
the same so now because she's got Nikki
whatever his name is poison lady six no
that's the I'm [ __ ] him whatever I'm
talking about the guy from poison that
comes in anyway it doesn't matter
while we drop in names here he left his
drumsticks here and as a souvenir and
she came and it took the drumsticks so I
told the John Bonham is the best [ __ ]
drummer so she [ __ ] she takes she
watches Moby Dick the video live from
the garden and she plays the drums on
her bed it's [ __ ] classic so anyway
forget about that my mother asked her
what she wants to give me for Father's
Day she goes how about a statue since I
took Jimmy Page how about a statue of
[ __ ] Robert Plant so they went on
line they couldn't fire Robin plant then
she went to the hobbyist she went to
Bruce Lee cuz she sits there and looks
at my books all day and there was no
statues of Bruce Lee so my wife goes I
don't know what to tell you you know
pick one and she started looking now
yeah my daughter watches Law & Order
yeah you know [ __ ] like that but nothing
dirty the a man had to switch down while
we're watching ray and she liked the
piano playing listeners he stuck the
needles all about us widget I don't you
know she's too young for that [ __ ] right
now
yeah I am I sure the excess was he was
five but that was a good situation
you got a scare a [ __ ] from time to
time you know I'm saying so uh yeah this
apartment ray where he bends over and he
grabs a little black boys hand his
brother when he was dead as she [ __ ]
jumped so right there I'm like I gotta
be careful and we switched this so uh
I've never watched nothing bad with her
and if something comes on the T like I'd
make a go inside a room when I watched
John on HBO on satellite Sunday nights
what's his name John Oliver right you
know cuz he'd [ __ ] go he curses more
than I knew that [ __ ] Englishman I
love him so I try to just be clean with
that you know whatever I don't try to
curse around I asked her if people say
bad words around there in school kids
her age she says sometimes you know same
[ __ ] over and over again
but here's the clinker so Sunday we get
back from doing a podcast her and I we
do a podcast about science and she gives
me a box she goes dad my [ __ ] your
passion not my [ __ ] your present came
open it up my wife looks at me
you want me to tell you what [ __ ]
statue she got me find me I'm smoking a
number here you know I'm saying it's
[ __ ] Wednesday morning you gotta do
what you gotta do it's hump day for some
it's slinging dick day for others and
you know who your others are so she gave
me a [ __ ] statue of Tony Montana
sitting there there's no Coke no there's
no it's thank God because then I wanna
know when she gave me the Scarface to
him like I looked at my wife she goes
she packed it she picked it herself she
says that she liked the way he was
sitting down so I don't know what to
tell you guys maybe I'm doing the wrong
job here I don't know what the [ __ ] I've
never talked about below I'm never I
wouldn't even show her this movie till
she's 20 she could handle it
the [ __ ] arm getting cut off and [ __ ]
she wouldn't go for that so now there's
a [ __ ] statue here that's it that's
all I wanted to tell you I wanted to
tell you it's good to be alive it's a
beautiful day to be alive Russell Peters
came in the other day out of a favor he
wanted just to get out of the house and
we put a little podcast together for you
here it is I hope you enjoy
[Music]
what the [ __ ] Russell is going on with
the world counter no nobody knows what
the [ __ ] is going on with the world so
we nobody has a clue it is great to see
you brother you too brother you know and
once let me tell you mention up there
let me tell everybody you were the only
guy who checked on me consistently thank
you and and and I'm not a good friend
cuz I didn't check on you as much as you
checked on me I checked on everybody I
know you know man I know morale was
gonna be down and you're an empath I'm
once the comics I knew that I was doing
I know how I'm addicted to nighttime
mm-hm I know what it was to stay in
three nights five nights two weeks then
they kept extending it limbo and then
more limbo and guess what it's the 23rd
the 22nd June and we're still a [ __ ]
limbo the week and Brea this weekend is
not gonna happen
so if you were coming to Bray this
weekend my deepest apologies the brand
probably is gonna open up after July
15th then when they say that's what this
science so you know Orange County got
polluted again Houston is polluted
Florida triple I'm going to Florida this
week
IRA's on the triple so you know what
part of law are you going to win I am II
oh that's canceled Robert County's
[ __ ] up let's see what happens I hope
it doesn't get cancelled to be honest
with you how you been
oh you know I'm [ __ ] surviving this
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] have you been doing
to pass the time I used to do lies I
think everybody went through this whole
phase of going live on Instagram for a
while and I think it just fizzled out
they just loved it I stopped doing it
I'm doing the night o do whenever I felt
like it really and what would you talk
about I don't know I would just talk to
people and then I would see like like
friends of mine like rappers or DJ
friends of mine that would be in the
chat and I just add them in real quick
and we talk you could just add them in
and then they pop up yeah he'd be like
hey come on let's talk and then you know
everybody watch it copy it's like a
podcast at that point that's pretty
[ __ ] cool yeah hey Dom on with me one
night a little rel one night you know
the DJ that much anymore yeah
sometimes I'll deal with the problems
that they were cracking down on DJ's on
Instagram
oh like but it was really hypocritical
of me cuz they would let like and I
don't want I'm not [ __ ] on these
guys my name is because these are my
friends but they would let d-nice play
for hours and anything you wanted and
they would let Questlove play for hours
and anything he wanted and you know
certain guys they would let go and these
guys are having like eight ten thousand
twenty thousand D nights that with two
hundred thousand people on one of his
lives one time and uh and but then they
started like shuttin guys down and I
like I was DJing when I would having a
great time everybody was [ __ ] jam and
we're and then I got a message your
you've just violated instagrams policy
I'm like what the [ __ ] and then they
your live will not be saved I'm like
[ __ ] I went on a rant I posted on my
Instagram I don't know if you saw that
only if you follow me follow me down
here I don't know I don't know I'm
Misaka I don't know [ __ ] about sheet
listen let me tell you something about
the other night let me play how bad it
is I haven't had a drink since the thing
just because I'm scared and lowers you
don't drink anyway actually I heard it's
good for you I don't
there's no [ __ ] nothing no you know
what it's like it's like a trump
supporter and a not Trump supporter they
can both raise an argument for either of
their stances it's the same with the
kovat [ __ ] when this [ __ ] thing had I
started eating edibles I was home I was
lonely
I saw the even a tables you know my wife
was calling about an 8 o'clock with the
baby 8:30 and I was eating a tables at
night and in the daytime I was eating
xanax Oh little baby once like dog I I
had them for years and I never touched
and then the next thing on me there were
twelve O'Clock eating them at 3:00 and
then I would stop because I didn't
member when Duff came on and he said
that he would eat him at night and you
get addicted to them don't eat him at
night to go to hell because they go yeah
and I could man Rogen's guy when he did
the podcast on sleep he said not to use
things to help you go to sleep because
you won't go to your full REM cycle oh
really so I was like what I'll do is in
the daytime I'll take the babies a next
2.25 is not even the sticks mm-hmm the
circle still and addictive it's just a
comment old thing all right it's like a
teddy bear I go I believe three of those
in the day time might prescribe and then
act after five I would start popping
edibles and doc I was popping so many
edibles I was forgetting like I would
put two out and go and then my wife
would call on me and I come back and go
where's the two I wouldn't see those
when I pop two and then I'd go whoa I
didn't pop the two way and I pop two
more and then one night I was talking to
a friend on the phone so I JA you don't
sound too vit that's when I started
going wait a second I got a comment down
with and plus my world was just getting
[ __ ] when you eat edibles I can't
skeletons in the closet and it's late at
night and you start thinking about
stupid [ __ ] yeah stupid [ __ ] fifth grade
[ __ ] yeah you wore a stupid shirt oh
yeah the first time kids called you
names because you were [ __ ] colored
socks the gym you know like to do with
the [ __ ] what was going on in your life
nothing to do with kovat nothing about
comedy bringing back [ __ ] that
traumatized them in the first granite on
trouble for throwing the statues out the
window on the third floor PS 166 and
they [ __ ] told me they would call my
mother and I remember that [ __ ] I
remember everything that had none that
night and I came and I ma'am I told you
guys in the podcast that this type of
[ __ ] makes you think this [ __ ] that you
haven't thought of in years yeah it does
dig deep in you it digs deep in you so I
said [ __ ] it April came all I couldn't
work out I would hit the bag and I
couldn't breathe I couldn't catch my
breath hmm
I would feel the pressure on my neck I
thought I was gonna have a stroke
were you gonna pressure on your neck
from I don't know because the stress I
had in me then you know well there's a
comedy store gonna reopen what are we
gonna do with our comedy [ __ ] people
gonna starve I had all these horrible
things going on in my mind and now I
just something happened like I got
better I said I'm gonna stop with the
edibles let's stop with the elbows and
that really kicked it down 50% that was
50% of my anxiety that I got a bicycle
hmm the guy next door gave me a bicycle
I got one of those bikes with the motor
assist on it's [ __ ] incredible all I
should Gimenez that's perfectly yeah but
I got a bike and I started riding the
bike early 7 in the morning
oh yeah you know you would call him me
and tell me he was up at 7 I'm like what
the [ __ ] yeah yeah get up do a couple
notes post messages and [ __ ] brush
your teeth I took a shower before I went
to bed brush my teeth comb my hair
I wouldn't even eat breakfast no
breakfast maybe a little whatever I'm
coffee yeah
Cuban coffee too expressive get on the
bike and go you look off and I got on a
bike after Cuban cargo ship off
tremendous move you do three shots of
Cuban coffee a morning man you watch
those pedals move baby you know but I
remember the first like the third dad
without guys I went out with a mask and
I remember going today I'm doing 20
minutes and I'm at the end of the twenty
minutes like I looked at my finger had
19 the go I was completely drenched in
sweat it was one of those days and there
was 90 already at 8:00 my snot would
dripping yeah
under the mats now it's the worst I took
the mask off I'm like I'm not wearing
this mask no more than I ride a bike you
know at 7:00 in the morning
there's nobody out yeah today or last
week Newsom said you don't have to wear
massive the exercise nights I was like
oh thank god that bro I will look in the
mirror to piss
I had [ __ ] not even frozen snot it
was like snot that had been freeze dry
that into my lip I could taste something
salty but I didn't know what it was
until I cut my lip it was thus not just
dripping like just that was the further
third day I was on a bike that's out of
shape like how stressful with and then
you got the mask which is like [ __ ]
killing yourself to live with you yeah
yeah you're [ __ ] sucking and see a
mask was what I stopped be I start
yawning like crazy and I put that
goddamn mask on that's why I don't like
it
that's why don't [ __ ] like him once I
started adding that I gotta be honest to
you Russell things started slowing down
but let me tell you what I did I went
online I sag somebody sent me something
how to cope with stress during these
hard times and I'm when I started
reading it I said there's different
forms of [ __ ] you're gonna see I'm gonna
tell you story it said that
short-term memory yeah now I could
[ __ ] tell you what I did 1982 the
conversation what time I had it I swear
to you guys the other night me my wife
and my daughter were playing battleship
and we played till 9:00 my daughter went
to bed
me and my wife kept yakking at one point
I go let me go outside let me go take a
shower I look at the Sun burn I got
third-degree sunburn inventory so she's
peeling skin off me so I took a shower
came out I put my short time she comes
and she goes don't put your shirt on so
I could rub some aloe on he rubbed out
on me we talked for a little while I
went outside to the living room and she
said to me do you mind if I have a beer
then I had a rough day go you better get
to she goes I'm gonna go sit outside for
a couple minutes I went into my office
I started going you know writing notes
or whatever the [ __ ] I do at night it
must have been 10:45 I swear to you both
do you not one more point I go well I
can take a shower and something when I
went to get up I look down they looked
at my shorts and that's how I remembered
I took a shower my short-term memory has
been taking a [ __ ] what I was telling
you a story before we went on the air
and I couldn't member the [ __ ] member
I had to ask you I said was it what was
I saying and I was in the middle of
telling the [ __ ] story
horrible leap tell that [ __ ] tell you
bad don't stay at home that's not
[ __ ] that's a Jewish bug right there
that [ __ ] these aren't the kill
it's like Steve's a gallon [ __ ] maybe
someone but uh that's what it affects me
am I sure like I could not remember yeah
just saying a shower
however I can't remember if I took my
[ __ ] pills in the morning oh I do
that you know what time did I take it I
don't know did the bottom loop I can't
have the bottle thank God my wife has
Monday through France with Sunday no I
have those but then I have separate ones
that I take in the morning
they're like first thing and then I got
the pill boxes for downstairs and then I
mean I got a process I got it open up
the protein cabinet I got a spray
steroid in both nostrils mm-hmm and I
gotta take a guy that sideways [ __ ]
right there
and that I do uh I'll go for your
thyroid had to one of those then I eat
breakfast then I take my blood pressure
medication of my x them but with this
[ __ ] my stomach yep so but very similar
routines we have well I have the same
process I have to put the dish down and
go move right to the pills if for some
reason I put the dish down and I gotta
take a [ __ ]
I don't forget to take those [ __ ]
pills mm-hmm then all day long I'm
banging my head on the wall I take those
pills thank God my wife puts them and
monday to wednesday so I'll go back look
and go I didn't take them if not I'm
[ __ ] [ __ ] mm-hmm for me like
stuff that I usually like to do just I
don't feel like I'm depressed but like
everyone's watching TV I love TV I don't
watch i watch I'm watching sitcoms I've
watched eight thousand times cuz I can't
[ __ ] I don't want to sit down and focus
on the TV show I hope this is gone yeah
I can't watch it but I couldn't watch it
I watched something one night the next
one I didn't remember what I watched
like I'm like so I just thought of
watching mr. Pro knows sons of anarchy
and narcos from the beginning hmm and
every time I put him on there sleeping
pills just sleeping pill soon as I put
them on I wake up to tell you in the
morning I'm on the [ __ ] couch
honestly to get me to sleep I put porn
on this I don't know what it is about
the sound of it knocks me out
you don't jerk off no I think I'm going
to and then I watch and I'm like I go
home I guess I don't need to jerk off do
you watch porn when this when your wives
are now no sons my son's mother and that
we were never married just for the
record um no I mean we we weren't even
sleeping in the same [ __ ] room
anymore
that's always a thrilling
yeah I was up she was down whatever you
don't go to bed till 5:00 in the morning
no I tried to go to bed early I tried to
be in bed by like 11:30 12:00 o'clock
really yeah I thought you were a Night
Stalker
I used to be when I was a little younger
I can't do that [ __ ] no no I feel it the
next day I'd love to I'd love to stay up
till 3:00 I love to know that I could
stay up till 4:00 with no penalties and
go on to writings I could do that in New
York yes because you're gonna be up
anywhere I did it in New York all right
New York there's no problem step till
4:00 and I know I have the thing is in
New York you know you can get breakfast
had [ __ ] 4:00 in the afternoon so
you're okay I remember one night talking
to Lee and breaking his balls you had to
be one in the morning in New York I'm
fortunate about yeah like a salami
sandwich New York I wasn't of it then
you were here and I'm I called Lee and
I'm like what's going on he said nothing
that I'm just eating some well you don't
[ __ ] die you keep breathing that [ __ ]
and I'm not I don't hang out with him
two minutes I go downstairs I smoke a
joint I got a coffee I'm all those
[ __ ] drinks coffee at night oh
yeah
not anymore not anymore for me to go to
the store I need four shots of Cuban how
many de do you drink I drink American
coffee when I wake up he's gonna get the
party started
okay I'll drink regular nice dark roast
night like a dark roast - yeah I like it
laughs I drink it black black yeah hot
coffee to get the party started
that's the first party I'd like to pop a
little nicotine gum and that just gets
the blood muscles moving
hmm then I get up I do a couple light
Porto Rican yell B stretches like I
stretched my spine I touched my toenails
then I hit but to bond it's after I'm
about 42 minutes I'd do it by to bond
it's when the music is starting to sound
good
and once I inhale those two bonnets I go
into the kitchen
I drink like 10 ounces of cold cold cold
water hmm and then I blast a form an
expresso before I wash my [ __ ] No
before I think a shower I blast a form
an expresso and then I drink another
bottle of water and then after that
let's say I eat or how I eat oatmeal and
then do the 4-cup espresso and then
you're just waiting for you guts to come
out it's just a matter
oh yeah no I I came my body knows it's a
sign he's gone the computer you type a
couple things those things just you
ripped that fart and it smells like the
guts help you [ __ ] enemy it just no
like your [ __ ] ass and you're like
well I'm ready I go in the back bathroom
I got a door to the outside mm-hmm so I
don't kill here the bathrooms in the
house yeah and that's that first one
that's pure fire by this time is 7:45
I'm already throwing Heat it's a log my
asshole's on fire you know I mean it's
one of those things where you sit up you
what when you walk back you walk with a
limp shits you know saying it took
something out of your leg takes I mean
why I'm serious oatmeal a nice cup and a
half of oatmeal and then the fourth shot
of expresso what do you have in the
oatmeal you have sugars honey and
cinnamon cinnamon cinnamon and coconut
milk hmm can't [ __ ] with it mmm I like
my milk regular I'll do regular - well
if I'm if it's my wife if I know like my
wife's gonna get pizza I won't put dairy
okay I'll put coconut because you'll
have the dairy later I'll have the dairy
later and then that'll make me go
[ __ ] crazy
so I'm just going on with the rap game
you still producing the show with Paula
yeah we we did four seasons you know we
want an Emmy we want a Peabody and then
they didn't want if Netflix didn't want
a fifth like all right cool
I got another doc that I'm working on
okay
it's almost done he's not really old you
know I was thinking the one day I called
you
mm-hmm was because the edible I called
you Mel ate one
i quad you late to tell you a story
there was about 10:30 he was one calling
you didn't answer I called you late one
night because I was in the middle of an
edible run hmm I'm making an outline for
the book and I remember the history of
crack cocaine mm-hmm I'm thinking about
I grew up on a hundred 48th Street in
the Bronx no no no you were like
Washington I just younger like I was on
88th Street
my mother lived on th I went to public
school on 89th Street I Marcy where I
just uptown was an uptown guy yeah but
my godmother my Santeria got my live
done on her 48th Street now is if she's
Harlem almost she is horizontal now and
it was a great neighborhood I learned a
lot there a couple of blocks up he can
cross over to the to the into the
[ __ ] Yankee Stadium over there right
there 169 yeah both hand over so it was
that old block
not when I lived with my not when I was
with my godmother as I got older ten
years later I would go visit my
godmother I would surprise I'd bring a
flowers she talked to me and then on the
way out I just crossed the street and
cop Buddha tie weed they would sell
bootytime bootytime bootytime bootytime
this is 8281 oh yeah that's where
they're smoking Thai stick and Buddha
high stick and Buddha yeah and they
either soldier Buddha Thai stick or they
sold you sense of me it was the
beginning I was that close yeah and I'll
[ __ ] at narcos Mexico when they split
seven cents of me that was 1980 [ __ ] I
was a Jamaican one well the Jamaican one
was
lambsbread right that was what they sold
in the city that was big that [ __ ] you I
remember that why is it called lambs map
because it's some bad [ __ ] yeah people
don't even know about lambsbread play
very very very few people know the power
lambs bread you know they used to call
all that we chocolate I Buddha tire but
basically it was lamb right and it was
Jamaican weed and it [ __ ] you up and
then in like around 84 85 they started
smoking Willa blunts
or that was when the sensimilla started
coming around and then I had a
schoolteacher mr. Pohlman he used to
[ __ ] get Maui Wowi shipped to him
I remember now he well he would sell it
to you at school in a stick with
hilarious 35 hours for three joints
Jesus that was more than you ever paid
in your life how much was the regular
joint like a dollar joint
oh sure okay so you could buy a half
ounce of dirt weed and get you know pay
25 bucks and get 32 joints so I can make
seven dollars like that was you're
thinking him when you were a sophomore
in high school seven joints is 20 bucks
today so DCI my family I made 20 on 25
investment soured by a quarter pound for
a hundred bucks and sell for 200 right
off the bat I was doing hot [ __ ] in the
late 80s Wow and now hung out with a guy
that that's what we saw he was fronted
to me he would drive me he would drive
me give it to me I go upstairs and I
keep a hundred give him on that's how
quick I made $100 in those days that was
the eighth grade freshman year but it's
gone back to my godmother well I went
back in this Psalm 82 83 mm-hmm I went
to Colorado late III came back a little
rural at this in my godmother I was on
the shitless
mm-hm and then finally in 85 I had I
came up with love guts to go see my
godmother and I went down the stairs
might get some weed to go back to
Colorado well as I was waiting at the
light to cross I seen all these
[ __ ] putting cardboard down
[ __ ] like make them believe fighting
mm-hmm and then they would start
spitting on their backs and [ __ ] and
that was more or less that was a deal to
Lynette's and yeah 81 82 that was like
it was everywhere now like I had been in
such a cocaine closet I missed the
beginning of all that [ __ ] man never
forget want to hang on where's the
reefer who's out and the guy's like
ain't no reef on this block my mom this
is trailer of crack ville yeah I'm like
Oh
like you know crack Ville was 181st and
up oh yeah it hit the Bronx hard they
hit the Bronx hard crackers I had
friends my friends in the Bronx homies
crazy stories one of them was I go he
said he was on I said when did you quit
how long were you on crack for he goes
right up until around 97 I go are you
[ __ ] kidding later 97 goes he I had
it bad I go it goes you ever see those
movies and then those abandoned
buildings with the [ __ ] crackheads
everywhere and [ __ ] just strung out
it goes I was in those buildings [ __ ]
raw dog and these crackhead chicks I'd
surprise I don't have AIDS
but God a crack was [ __ ] up man I
could lay why the entire went to a crack
then I never went to a crack them did
you try crack yes here oh really
can you believe that here how was it mm
- Wow mm find it in mm mm row back crack
to 2003 they sold it on orange and salma
my Hollywood right down the block Mann's
Chinese Theater Wow if you cross just ya
know a building right there and you walk
down then you hit Hollywood high school
parking at down the corner there'd be
two guys there every night standing it
so I'd be [ __ ] up in the coke and
drinking at the Comedy Store so I Drive
on some all the way along cross island
cross LaBrea and then by the time I got
to Orange you know every night they
would stare at me and I would stare at
them and one that I go what's all this
staring about what's crackin and he goes
back you know he didn't say crack he
goes I got a rock yeah sliced let me go
to 2010 he [ __ ] letting him go and
took a bag I gave it to me I'm like
alright see you later that's all
yeah with a baggie with a twist tie [ __ ]
they hide in their mouth right so he
gives me the bag and [ __ ] I go home
my girl that the time was not my wife
was sleeping and I took it home and I
[ __ ] crushed it up this is our stupid
uncle joey's I crushed that [ __ ] rock
up to death it was a mountain of coke I
[ __ ] snorted and I sat there for 20
minutes and my throat got a little numb
but not napping the parties in started
in the jerk-off man and that's that told
the dear friend of mine that was a
[ __ ] animal
well I didn't he was this on your crack
stupid you gonna [ __ ] get a three
basic [ __ ] on it
you gonna smoke that I got a you smoke
crack I didn't know because you gotta
get a pipe and on my ride so next night
went over there again I bought crack and
I put in a coke and I went home cracked
up a coke can't put holes in it and I
started smoking crack and I smoked crack
for about six weeks
my wife would wake up in the middle of
Lango Joey what's that smell and that
would go into new reefer I gotta go back
to bed I would buy for Rock six Rock how
was it it was disgusting it was part of
my disgusting days no no but I had it
was the buzz like on it I was like a
cousin took ok not at that time
Russell it was like 2001 hmm it was all
the same it didn't matter what night it
was
you know it just it's all one big blur
now but hey I was I smoked crack for
about six or seven weeks and then I had
a two-week run in El Paso he used to
hire me for like two weeks
so he would hire me for like one week to
open up for Russell as a feature and he
liked me so much he'd go want you to do
me a favor open for me like you know
that was a feature well that was a
feature headliner you know I could have
line yeah that was really a strong
feature he might say open up for Russell
stay because he had a condo they gonna
stay and then do a show Wednesday by
yourself and then Russell's cousins
coming in Friday and Saturday and then
you do Sunday you had lunch
that and I would do that so when I went
down there nobody's got cracking off the
hassle they got the real thing mm-hmm
like they walk it over yeah you they
just walk it over you know Zane mhm
you could call Mexico where you at ID me
they're dead minute
I'm also the [ __ ] a [ __ ] sewer
plate pops up the Mexican comes home but
other said like Felipe on a on Three's
Company cocaine everywhere
so when I went down there looked to
crack I couldn't find it
so what back there's no cover that's how
I got really cracked I remember I
remember was must have been around 1994
and I was driving in Toronto I thought I
was flying Saturn Oh actually must've
been 95 because I had rims on it already
that's Adam but it had no I'd have no
a/c I didn't have power windows nothing
said to roll down all the windows and
had a sound system that I put in the
trunk and I'm driving through this crack
head part of town and I'm at a red light
musics playing as a girl standing at the
corner she's cute she looks at me and
smiles ago what's up I go where you
going she goes I'm going that way I go
get in so she gets in she goes thanks
you take me I'm going to my uncle's I go
ahead cool no problem cuz do you mind if
I smoke I got now go ahead she pulls out
a [ __ ] asthma inhaler puts a rock on
it and starts lighting up in my car go
you know what the [ __ ] he's smoking she
goes I know it's bad habit I go no no
cigarettes are a bad habit you're
[ __ ] smoking crack in my car I go
watch smoke some weed you've got some I
go actually yeah cuz I was selling weed
at the time I go actually yes I do
so she goes oh good so I went to her
uncle's with her some shady ass building
I walk in uncle's there you know he got
weed yeah yeah so I sold him some weed
and it's got the [ __ ] out cuz I got I'm
gonna get shot stabbed whatever's gonna
happen in here you know when you tell
stories like this it's like when I tell
stories like this and it's crazy because
people can't fathom that no they don't
realize how [ __ ] weird our lives are
how
you'd and crazy position you know when
you come to Hollywood as a woman as a
young man you see tanks you know these
women that complain this that you know
they see something and you just get
sucked in by it like at a zone there was
nine parts in my life I could name nine
situations in my life
well at one point I said to myself I
really don't belong yeah I thought I
said anyway [ __ ] day I say this you
know this isn't Who I am at all I didn't
come here to see a guy get beat okay I
hit head with a pipe well you know I see
my stepfather's shoot a guy at a I did I
wasn't participant to all that stuff one
story that I told on our East I didn't
tell the full creepiness though was when
I sold that guy the stolen thing and he
gave me 60 bucks and he gave me some
heroin that was like a horrible night
for me I made it funny but if I really
sat down with people and described what
happened to me that night and how there
was an old lady but the whole time
we did we did coke first and then he's
like you you should try this heroin I'm
16
oh wow I'm 16 he's 29
Oh - [ __ ] no yeah he looked like [ __ ]
Tony Iommi from Black Sabbath but he was
cool with all my friends like he was one
of the older guys that we were cool with
and when I came in here he would you
want a [ __ ] I got a girl in the
bathroom that likes to suck dick why
he'd take this [ __ ]
oh right there just hearing that that's
dramatic for some people I'm like now
I'm good like nah I'm good bro I wasn't
in to discuss yet I was still a Catholic
my mother had died right and I hadn't
lost my faith yet and I was like man I'm
okay I just want to pick up the 60 bucks
dad you know and he's like well [ __ ] out
let's do a couple lines and he came out
and did we did the heroin when I was on
the heroin he asked me 10 times like he
should he don't want that check to suck
your dick like it was so disturbing
looking at it now I didn't make it
disturbing I was a joke
you know it was a [ __ ] joke now I
look at it as kind of funny but I didn't
belong there that night you know I
didn't belong there what you know so
nobody really belong it's kind of weird
when you have stories like that that I
checked out in your car I was in Montana
I'd love to say Missoula but it could
have been Billings I know it wasn't
Billings it was either Missoula or one
of those I get to the [ __ ] Club
Russell I'm a junkie but I'm in Montana
what am i chance is a copy mm-hmm unless
the way the kitchen guy is Mexican like
I was in South Dakota one time I made
eye contact with The busboy
next thing you know I was snorting coke
you know he was the only Puerto Rican
Italians in the Prioress
he was in the service and on the
weekends he watched dishes at this
restaurant I did comedy at which it was
a Tribble run you know I'm saying so you
could cop and not the green Dakota South
Dakota something you can stop anywhere
but I'm in Montana I'm not looking to
cop I'm not looking I'm not even
thinking you're probably not in your
head you're probably looking forward to
a weekend of being clean yeah I was like
I'm doing Montana Portland
maybe I'll cop and I think Saturday I
was like I know I could cop at that
place yeah so Hannah Montana hi how you
doing Jodi is the feature Act I'm the
emcee nice to meet you the emcee goes up
on stage Dona comes over he goes this is
my daughter girl was [ __ ] beautiful
tall and you know I tell her what you
want if you're hungry he walks away I'm
thinking this girl goes to like Yale she
had that Yale looking to look and the
girl says this is how you doing how is
you drivin it's the hotel fine for you
you know how people ask those bad
generics but right now she looks me in
the eye and she goes if there's anything
you need I mean anything ask me okay
let's start off with the basics because
before I buy the [ __ ] lobster
Cantonese I gotta try to poke fried rice
I know you got Reva
yeah what do you want I thought no it
makes the steel off quick to refill yeah
does I'll be right back
left came back boom reefer she does
anything else I don't know let me go on
stage and I'll think about it
I will not stay to go on stage they paid
me I pulled her in silent and you get
some powder she knows it's not here I
gotta go for a ride if you want to come
the fee track would mean I don't really
want them to know what's going on so she
goes I just bring it to yellow okay you
know half hour I gotta call him the
hotel room I didn't have a cellphone
then and she's like I'm on my way I'll
be there she showed up it's very nice
nothing sexual nothing she sat down she
left do you mind if I do a taste I don't
know go ahead and I had stopped to get
like beers I got a beer for her when I
turned around though she was taking out
a rig and I'm late
what are you doing is she goes I don't
snort that that's what [ __ ] she does
I shoot it oh wow Christ so who would
expect to see somebody mmm shoot coke a
woman who's beautiful by the way
this was not some girl with [ __ ] up
teeth and a broken car this girl had a
dad who owned the bar she went to
college she didn't snort coke she was
shooting if you thought I expected to
see that and whatever Montana no no not
at all you know Rico I know a fury with
the spider on his face from Seattle big
black guy he's a Muslim no I went to one
of those times with him one time on the
darkest there was three Booker's that
had rooms in Missoula mm-hm or like one
of those towns like one of those college
town I've never been in Montana
Tribble Billings is a Billings is a
great comedy town Tribble Dinah Richards
and somebody else another lady from
Seattle booked a room where we Don that
about Montana Montana Rico and we took
that what will Rico now this is an
all-white town this was before the check
this was like two years maybe five years
before I went with and the chick hooked
me up at the bluff this is I'm still
living in Seattle
it's March of 96 97 96 Rico's six foot
six three hundred and fifty pounds and
black it was beautiful and on his face
he has a spider he let his beard grow
but he pays a guy to shape into a spider
he's ganar into Doug Stanhope Rico's
cool this [ __ ] he was there when the
cops are looking for me now to jump in
the garbage can when I came out he's
like where are you in the cops saw him
and I'm like Rico you six-foot [ __ ]
six three hundred pounds in you're
waving your eyes and there's cops
everywhere I couldn't run to you I told
you to pick me up in front of the
[ __ ] hurricane lounge not a hundred
yards away from the [ __ ] hurricane
lounge so right away the cops come I
gotta jump in a garbage can they
couldn't figure out I was in the [ __ ]
garbage can the cops I go Rambo move I
pull we talking about so we do the gig
me and Rico biggest blackest guy you see
a maker yeah he's a comic in Seattle now
he's good friends with Doug Stanhope
okay it was hand Doug Mitch Hedberg
every time we did see out it was a party
with those guys we used to laugh when I
ran it for sure Doug Stanhope
you should go hold on ladies and
gentlemen real quick my friend I want to
give him a minute guest spot he would
give us one minute guest spots in those
days me Rico done yeah oh Jesus you have
one minute go he'd listen and you would
have one minute to do material issues
when Doug was like just before he walked
them yeah before he unleashed the last
hell of fury that when they were all
beat up and [ __ ] this is Doug Stanhope
96 97 nobody had seen that type of [ __ ]
yet he was out of his [ __ ] mind
but I mean out of his mind Russ
I mean when you watch this show you like
I don't believe this is happening type
[ __ ] he's tamed down anybody watches no
special I haven't I don't watch anybody
special
you have to he says early she he's a
[ __ ] nut I remember his act from back
in the day yeah he was out there oh yeah
he was like the original [ __ ]
alternative so we [ __ ] went to a
diner the next morning we order
breakfast the food cows it's filled with
white people
Greek those stands up he's Muslim he
gets on the Floyd clothes like I [ __ ]
think that and he starts praying on the
floor and a restaurant in Montana me I
may believe like I didn't know you
shoulda seen me at that moment in my
life no black lives matter I was with
them I was like Dawg just gonna shoot
him and I can't do this I just kept
eating my eggs like I didn't know me
[ __ ] when he said back at the table I'm
like who you think I was like [ __ ] it
was nuts six foot six 300-pound Muslim
in Montana this is like way before 9/11
[ __ ] or they would have [ __ ] killed
him oh I remember my friend's father was
on crack back in the day in the mid 80s
I would go to his house and his dad
would he'd get lockjaw from it some
chicken like it was wrong with the dead
he's on right he's on rock right now oh
my god okay we didn't even think about
it was like oh my god it was like an
after-school special just like oh okay
and then we just go to the store and
steal some chicken and then one night I
slept over I slept on the couch in the
in their place middle a night I got to
go to the bathroom I open the bathroom
door his dad's in there with a dude and
another chick in there [ __ ] shooting
up oh sorry it's closed yeah
the world the drug is a dirty [ __ ]
business man yeah dirty business it's
funny cuz I saw his dad like a couple of
years ago and I was like hey
clean that goes yeah yeah yeah go and
you were [ __ ] up in the eighties man
you were doing rock I walked in on your
doing heroin did I go yeah yeah well
right in that he was you I forgot his
name and then there's some chick in
there too because that was a good time
back then there's good times right I
will tell you one day I do get pissed
off when I watch narco sometimes I can't
lie to you not the Mexican ones the
other ones the Colombian ones because
the government no oh yeah they got
killed we got killed you know this cold
bean epidemic that was a cocaine
epidemic and people were losing
themselves right in front of me losing
themselves in front of me I remember
going to school with a girl that was the
sweetheart funny drank partied but had
her head on right was going to a good
college a mother was uh a big-time the
post office put away money for her to go
to some big-time college and right
before [ __ ] and come on a college time
I was a dropout I would want me and this
girl with friends we were friends with
dear friends I know a mother no brother
no father and she would just drop out on
me like you talk to him lately
no I haven't talked to him today didn't
want her girlfriend to call you see away
ah that's weird she was supposed to call
me to go do it and then she come back
like nothing happened
mhm this one on for months months of
what on and then finally like college is
starting and I'm like he's in college
so the deal where she would go to school
during the week and then come back on
the weekends and then we would see a
Friday night ready to go she would be
right there with her snorting drinking
Shane around again disappeared then when
I started getting calls from mother I
got a call from the college she hasn't
been in school in a month do you know
where she is you have to know like she
was accusing me you know and I'm like I
don't [ __ ] know girlfriends are
calling me you know is she I don't
[ __ ] know she was around while she
was running with a married dude
oh wow that was a gangster snorting tons
of blow called Atlantic City gettin
[ __ ] the top room in there and you
know what one night they were driving
all over they kept it a secret and they
were driving [ __ ] home from Atlantic
City they were driving I totally am
there were chances and they [ __ ] hit a
couple a seventy-year-old couple on the
way to church and kill them what she
went to County Jail she found that she
was pregnant no from that guy from the
guy from the married he was driving all
right he was driving but they had been
on a three-day bender so he got charged
with vehicular manslaughter he went away
she in the shame of the family picked up
and they moved the way she just popped
up on Facebook couple years did she have
the kid oh yeah the kid is gorgeous the
kid is gorgeous but it's just amazing
how I don't even know what made me tell
you that story just that's how fast your
life could change though well you were
saying it you with no clothes because
the government did it to us to come and
enter us and they knew it like by 85 and
I saw people break I have a lot of
people who died and I saw people who had
fucked-up lives for the last 30 years
I'm not blaming it I'm not saying that I
wasn't gonna do coke but now to find out
that our own government was shipping it
in and the CIA and Barry seal and all
that [ __ ] it kind of [ __ ] upsets you
a little bit that there was a pandemic
bro it was like I knew you I grew up
with you Lee you've never done anything
wrong awesome I go to a club in the city
and there's Lee sweating yeah which goes
and he's like I know I became a coke
dealer what what do you mean you became
a coke dealer ye laundry when I know you
for four years you're an A student
I changed powders like that that's how
quick people had become dealers father
team's mother father son teams
gave up their investments went to Miami
and they would try to
become pirates they would call there was
a name for them in fact Miami Vice did
an episode about that like the third
episode about kids from New York they
thought they were gonna be kingpins and
they would go to Miami with 60 G's and
[ __ ] go up to somebody on the street
you don't want to get two helos I have
$60,000 oh yeah 312 the Hilton next
thing you know six [ __ ] stop with the
rain Ian's coming in there with knives
taking your money they were doing that
[ __ ] to everybody you couldn't you
couldn't just go to Miami and buy a kilo
they would take your money right in the
hotel room they would shoot you write
those down take your money and Miami in
the 80s was crazy it was crazy I have
friends that went down and got set up I
can have one of them calling Danny beat
Danny be got set up down there friend of
ours called them go down there bring the
money
they went down as six people popped out
of a closet and cuffed us and took their
money that was a big business in the
beginning unless you knew somebody for
sure like I got a guy you could see that
his name is Russell go to Miami but you
were just going down and they give up
your [ __ ] money
but father-son teams people gave up
there was like their bank accounts to
make an investment in cocaine it was
thirty thousand a key a hundred a gram
all day long everybody knew was a
hundred there was no discount and when
you did the math on paper and the
calculator
it was the profit was amazing and you
were not gonna get stuck with it you
were not gonna get stuck with it but I
talked to a friend of mine two days ago
I've been seeing his post on Facebook
not too good so I picked up the phone I
know from the sixth grade uh-huh and he
blatantly said to me goes to 80s didn't
do me no favors he goes I became a drug
addict I lost my kid now I'm [ __ ]
this age I got this much from left in my
401k and you know the eighties [ __ ] up
some people I was one of them it was
fast
I still remember an 82 selling
half-grams thinking I was the sixth
family three of my friends thinking we
were the sixth family
and this kid came up to loo and in
effect who a friend of mine is listening
to this right now his name is Timmy
Holloway he's my dog and he'll vouch for
that story that we had a dude named
Steve there was a place there was a crew
called the six family wasn't it
nah yeah it probably was but there was a
four the five families of somebody had
have all Hispanics no no this is just a
joke no there really was though no it
probably and in New York that probably
was yeah there's a joke that's just a
joke we thought we were young we were
the Mafia yeah and we were solid and
awesome this Kent comes to me when then
he goes hey man
this is pimple wants to meet you I'm
[ __ ] 18 years old and a pimp wants to
meet me
yeah I gave him some of your coke and
it's the best [ __ ] around he wants to
buy volume from you so right away I'm
thinking he's an undercover cop psycho
all right I got like an 8-ball let's go
downtown it was in North Bergen so I
know wouldn't make the papers I wouldn't
get arrested
there she liked I know I can maneuver
myself out of there it's not perfect the
paperwork or disappear the evidence will
disappear it's my hometown I know
friends that friends are the cops some
will happen you know so I Drive down and
this kid kept saying tremendous we think
I got the word tremendous room
it was that day that's why I got the
word tremendous for Chinese restaurant
and Mississauga kept real time called
tremendous I'm like where's his kid
living he's he's in a hotel on in Jersey
City on the border of North Bergen in
Jersey City and every time we do some so
the kid was in the backseat I was in the
front passenger seat and the kid who was
driving was not the type of kid you
could play with he didn't like what was
about to happen
he liked slowing coke but this wasn't
his world the other short temper if you
know what I mean he didn't take a lot of
[ __ ]
so I would tell the kid tell us where
we're going he's like just come straight
on telling the Avenue and then he go
like lick lick lick that left over there
and like my friend would [ __ ] go what
the [ __ ] is wrong with you make the left
and the guy in the back we go that left
was tremendous
a couple miles lay they again make it
right over there my foot [ __ ] is wrong
with you
I gotta cut off three people that right
that was tremendous you know let me get
a blast of the coke that cocaine is
tremendous and finally my brother gonna
say tremendous one more time my day I'm
gonna beat the [ __ ] out here and we
started laughing have henceforward
because it's so annoying I say
tremendous we went inside this seedy
hotel room black guy Michael Jackson
hair way before the operation you know
Yankee black white chick skanky white
chicks got beat up there Runaways
cigarette burns on their legs I walk in
there with my buddy and Steve tremendous
and the guys like man I need your coca
it all comes back like what the [ __ ] you
thought about that did you cope it all
comes back and he showed me out of
freebase she goes no I don't do that
punk ass noise [ __ ] I freebase this
[ __ ] and he would [ __ ] take
it cook it put it through a sock a silk
sock he would take it off his foot [ __ ]
oh and put it through the like the high
part of it and the rock would say on the
thing and develop and he would shave it
and you smoking and I was hooked dogs
I'm like what cuz I was the big white
people [ __ ] by 82 white people already
freebase it
Wow minorities we were still putting
coke rocks in our nose the people from
steno hahaha those people well like we
don't do it we wouldn't want to hurt our
noses we'd rather put baking soda and
smoke it so they were already often
running white people why people were
already acting goofy it's like they are
with the what's that [ __ ] they smoke
about that yeah they couldn't those are
the same people same people that smoke
dabs today are the same people of a free
basis in the eighties they couldn't just
smoke reefer they couldn't just not go
oh no we got a freebase and these people
I went to this head shop all in and out
it's still there anything no I forget
what the way in and out that's a burger
place I went to a head shop that's still
then had a free batches a freebase kid
you believe that I remember those head
shops and there was a lot of survival
there that head shop it was a freebase
kit and 50 bucks I'm like am I [ __ ]
there's a half a gram of coke I gotta do
this and I move went to a friend's house
we brought like 13 grams of coke in the
bottle and we [ __ ] burned it all up we
smoked it all I'm M is waking up and of
all the bottles of turns upside down the
pipe was there there were bodies laying
everywhere and I was like that's the end
of my freebasing career it was too much
drama we get high wait I gotta wait for
it to dry
forget it just give it to me straight
seems like more opportunities to get
caught yeah you just hanging on to it
for a long time yeah it's just all these
excessive made you pad it like it I
didn't like that part when you and
Toronto you exposed although you were in
class I mean I didn't do any of it but I
was around it you mr. anta yes of course
what time the bars stay open two three
four your time in Tehran runs good they
stop serving it too but it's not like
here where they [ __ ] not see you out
of your bottles at 1:30 at to two
o'clock when they stop serving they let
you keep your drinks out till 3:00 love
we used to go to Hollywood what was that
climb of debt that the magician read oh
you played there that was Toronto
it was Boris this club Boris you know it
was a [ __ ] club called comedy would
calmly would I've totally about the
story I did though we the wing club up
there was Steve well Stephen into the
weed club but on that one though though
a woman who knows that pop mama it was a
waitress I think at that club
yeah cuz she'll remember you guys yeah I
never played that club cuz I was a yuk X
guy okay if you were you could tell you
weren't allowed to work anywhere else
right no I remember one time going to
Toronto and having a really like weird
good time
like eight you were there fro you had a
golden where that club was was in the
middle of [ __ ] nowhere yeah but then
you got to go down there for two weeks
yeah he will hire you as a headliner for
two weeks
Wow and so you had two weeks in Toronto
you off Sunday and Monday you lived on
top of the club you slept over the club
in these little hallway rooms he had and
there was a shower
it was good enough for me in those days
you know yeah on the way up and
everything is fine waiting is great I
would with honesty I'd have no
complaints about anything and be the
worst [ __ ] places you've ever stabbed
you like that's fine but that was one
week where they had movie theatres or
waitresses that was the one week where I
lost my mind on blood street at the
strip club like I really I its Yonge and
Bloor it's like your ass rail Brass Rail
those are strip club oh yeah old old
those are the strip clubs I grew up in
anything goes shoot them whatever you
want to do no you have to just pay him
you know I mean I was really impressed
not only like strip clubs I said I don't
want to [ __ ] trip himself my friend
calls him wants to toots oh my god does
they want a prostitute but they can't
commit to it they were crazy they were
crazy there was a place on there that
sold scripts on Bloor Street that sold
my whole scripts I still got Goodfellas
signed Wow
yeah they still had a bunch of [ __ ]
there there was a great city and I tell
you what I met up there I met a Cuban
refugee that was one of Fidel's
bodyguards really he I met him at the
club and then he took me out the next
day for lunch he took me to a small
Cuban neighborhood they have mm-hmm it's
like maybe two blocks long he showed me
some [ __ ] interesting pictures ain't
told me some wild stories about being
Fidel's bodyguard you're only in the
rotation for three years then you
disappeared apologies and I never see
you again they tell you that he went
it's a good different division but you
be years later you'll talk to something
go house Lee don't
Lee who Lisa anyone up there I work from
their window the same way again
he was saying that Fidel was shooting
his bodyguards because you knew too much
information about her so he felt he was
next
so he shot to the United he shot the
Toronto and that's where they took a man
and then he tried to get shot up there
so the government protected him he had a
great spring he was telling me some
[ __ ] tremendous Fidel Castro stories
walking into restaurants or Fidel my
Fidel would see a young woman that was
attractive well as she was married and
not one of his lieutenants would come up
to you and say excuse me mr. Peterson
may I have a word with your wife and
your wife would get up and he'd go
tomorrow morning call this number the
commandante want you to call the number
and ye'll communist so you call the
number and it would pick you up and take
you to the doctor give you a BB test
they ship you different dolls house to
get [ __ ] Wow they would check you out
and everything will they make sure you
helped you had no cancer they would give
you a blood test and then take your
right to Fidel's whether you were
married or not he had some great stories
well I mean if you're a dictator that's
the way to do it I suppose right for the
Gulf to me and so it means to be a
[ __ ] like yeah swinging dick and
giving out [ __ ] medical cards slinging
dick and eating taters what do you think
brother what do you think of this whole
thing talk to me
what thing no work how long do you think
it'll last person I went back to work I
I didn't I did my quarantine I did at
least two and a half months straight
clean out of work you got to your West
bar you wear this week Miami coming up
then after that way you don't then I'm
not working the week after cuz it's
fourth of July I think okay and then I'm
in I got a whole run going now
that is crazy Russell after that I'm in
stand-up live in Phoenix and then I'm in
the raha improv in Raleigh are you
really going on yeah and then I'm in
Indianapolis at helium then verge of
Virginia Beach funny bone you flying
prime st. Louis helium you fly private
all you know those days are over
those days are over buddy
Nashville Zanies Nashville is no direct
flight no I know
Irvine yeah at all Portland coming up in
September
yeah it's all it's all filling up there
Sacramento punchline in October I mean I
don't I don't see many free weekends to
be honest with you you go flopping
trooper brother I'm a Road Dogg what's
the inspiration the [ __ ] baby's mama
oh you really want you know I love what
I do
hey listen Russell I love what I do too
I just don't do you have a nice home
life I hear what you say I need to get
away
oh yeah I miss my kids when I'm away you
know but I mean I altum Utley I'm
working for them right yeah that's the
same thing with me yeah but you also got
the luxury of having the podcast and it
being a successful podcast yeah but it's
not all fun it was to me and Lee were
talking about this before it's been
rolling with the punches lately well I
mean yeah Tommy did what's going on now
they were all coming and wouldn't nobody
pay attention to the podcast oh yeah
things going on now those other things
aren't going on yeah I remember doing
Jose in his house ten years ago yeah you
know when you'd walk in the front door
and you'd hang a right into that little
last room he'd cut through the garage or
something and hey you cut through the
garage and the room was on the right
there and then he moved it to ice house
and then he moved it to that other place
in Woodland Hills then he moves on the
other place that he's in now it just
crazed the evolution of what happen with
this [ __ ]
nobody knew no nobody knew nobody see it
coming and those are the biggest
movements like this movement now at them
you never so [ __ ] come of this
pandemic well we never saw this
broadcast coming yeah everybody was like
why don't you start a podcast I go in
and I feel it's disrespectful for me to
do it right now cuz like everybody's got
one I don't abuse another [ __ ] one
and they in the fish tank it's tough to
start one right now yeah I know it so
I'm like it doesn't make sense I mean if
you were to start this right now people
will look at you like it's a real doubt
it's a real battle you have a huge
following so you got to hope that
podcast listeners you better hope that
they won't pay attention to you on that
forum you know it's really weird one
time I had one of the biggest names of
calmly on here
and it was the lowest numbers I have I
had an Apopka really that's how that's
how I don't wanna say no that's how
awkward this is that's how much I've
learned I've learned that yeah it's
really not who you have it's it's what
you're talking about how you know well
that they want the information that's
one thing I'm talking about when you
look at again this [ __ ] reform my age
when you're looking that not even the
guest or what you're talking about I
know what we're talking about so it
doesn't matter talk about how the
podcast may or may not work I just
didn't know but we started when I
started with Felicia we were just
talking about random [ __ ] I was just
trying to copy a radio show that's it
and then one day I'm like wait a second
this is what you hear on the radio this
is like people don't want to hear this
yeah people don't want to hear the voice
whenever you're being real people want
to hate you being real and I still
remember telling the story about mother
in the hook-up and like looking at her
and her like this and me going I just
struck a chord this is what I need to
talk about and sure enough this is when
it all started I mean telling a story
from Burt it was telling the Machine
story on Rogan it just ran like a [ __ ]
you know yeah I remember doing Burt's
podcast maybe six years ago and yeah
came to my house and we did it it was
just it's basically an interview that's
it and that's why I don't like doing
some guy's podcast is like so don't you
tell everybody how you got started
you're a comic don't ask me that you
know these questions those are the worst
things you can ask us to do I've always
tried to go against your grain
I've always want to print out a
conformist so we don't have to work I
don't want to hear listen if I go on the
news everybody's talking about something
then that's the last thing I want to
talk about but this is the problem I see
a lot of people want your specific data
yeah they want your take on the
situation yeah what do you think about
blob what do you think about blah blah
blah I don't think nothing about blah
blah blah I'm dead and buried what do I
think about blah blah blah and we're
shape than you are in him Sam what do I
think about blah blah blah so I can't
I just wanted why did this podcast I
wanted to let people know that we've
been getting blood that they lied to you
your guidance counselor lied to you
oh yeah people lied to you you don't
need to do this this is what you need to
do I never went to college and if I'm a
felon and I could do it hmm
and they told you you can't do nothing
like they pretty much tell you in prison
once you get out of here you're dead
you'll never be able to get a job people
want my you cuz you're a felon in fact
you should sign up for disability now
mmm that's what they tell you sign up
with disability now because my buddy got
out he signed up for disability yeah
well you did 33 years yeah and what's he
gonna do now now he's dead did he really
died during this thing really he died he
hadn't even been out four years that he
died three and a half years out that I
used for what bodies bodies had a few
bodies 14 in the hole no [ __ ] 14 in the
hole I got his light I got light of the
rights to his life story how'd they
catch him he was in that they did a
robbery or something and he was in a car
the getaway car and the guy you know
[ __ ] they ran over somebody crossing
the street and they you know it was a
big mess I tell you that's one place I
look at now and I don't want to be in he
was in every supermax prison on the East
East Coast every they would move him all
the time
he's causing problems here you need to
go
oh the it was humor problem closer to
him he was like a shot-caller so they'd
move him he was like moving every [ __ ]
you want I know I got my people
everywhere that's crazy
33 [ __ ] here 33 he died ten days
before his 63rd birthday and I was the
second person on the call sheet from the
hospital how did you become friends I
met him about maybe two weeks after he
got out he was friends with a friend of
mine who uh a friend of a friend of mine
who who stayed in touch with him and
looked out from the entire time he was
in jail whereas everybody [ __ ] off on
him somebody came out we were in New
York and I'm just talking to him you
know I just see Porto Rican guys for
Leonard you know was talking hanging out
and then we're talking he tells me just
got out like what I go I sent my friend
ago yo he just kind of goes yeah
how long do you do 3333 five you are you
[ __ ] kidding me and at the time I was
doing real well too so I mean I took him
to Macy's I bought him a whole new
wardrobe so yeah you need to look right
and then there was a Gucci in their
bottom Gucci shoes Gucci belt Gucci
jacket bottom a new phone iPad all that
[ __ ] to set him up right this guy loved
me after that you know sure you would
but it's first his first his first
murder was um first murder was when he
was 11 she killed these twins and his
projects who were bullying everybody he
was 11 and these twins were about 17 and
he goes down to play with one of his
friends and his friend looks all [ __ ]
up because what happened here goes those
[ __ ] twins they robbed me and they
beat me up cuz they can't do that my
brother's got a gun and he goes up and
gets his brother his gun and he finds
one and goes pop pop pop shoots him and
then he goes to the corner where the
other one is yo something happened to
your brother he comes over pop pop
shoots that one-two goes into juvie
psych for for four years comes out like
14 15 there's a run on the streets then
when you kill somebody 11 yeah the rain
don't come and his brothers were like in
that life you know but but it's weird
because his uh his family wasn't like a
broken family they weren't and they were
the only family in the his in his
project building that were not on
welfare cuz his dad owned a bunch of
bodegas and some meat shops some
butchers and so I kind of [ __ ] butcher
shops and some simple Degas and
everybody loved his family because his
dad would tell you when you came into
the story goes listen you don't [ __ ]
steal from me you don't rob for me you
don't rob me if you need something and
you don't got the money you come and
tell me and you write me an IOU and you
pay me whenever you can and everybody
loved his family for that it was really
revered in the hood Fort Greene you know
yeah yeah I just when you say the number
33 it just crinkles my [ __ ] oh I
don't think a Larry Bird I think a 33
hard long years oh dude 14 in the hole
really it was 12 he got seven well it
started with 12 he does because he
killed the guy in the yard for this
[ __ ] guy just he killed him whatever
him just been long story short he killed
the guy in the yard he got put in for 12
while he was in the hole you know you
can talk to each other through the walls
was a guy in the in the cell next to him
you don't see each other you just hear
his voice guys talking [ __ ] to him for
about three years three years this guy's
talking [ __ ] [ __ ] you you're a punk
you're a [ __ ] I'll [ __ ] kill you you
ain't [ __ ] I know who you are you
[ __ ] [ __ ] and my guys like all right
you watch imma find you he gets out of
the hole after 12 years his hairs long
beards long he'd go everyone's like
y'all welcome back man you know I need
to cut a barbershop oh it's the
barbershop starts leaning back and it
there's a guy in the chair beside him
his eyes are closed he's just getting
his [ __ ] done here's the guy talking in
the chair beside him that was the guy he
got up if I can stab him and went right
back in the hole for two more years
at least he made this statement okay he
wasn't the guy you were gonna look huh
there's guys that make you know and he's
a little guy he wasn't like a big guy
and he wasn't like a diesel guy he was
like a gibe like I don't know I think I
easily could take the guy but nope you
had a [ __ ] streak in him he had
something we don't have you know what I
mean the ability to do something we
would never have to die we'll never be
able to do just listen there's murder
and then this doing 33 [ __ ] years
oh yeah and doing 12 in the hole I mean
14 you know I was talking to think Rogan
on the phone and we were talking about
this whole thing in the walking home in
Minneapolis
Nieves and how that guy they have to be
watching him they have to but his his he
knows it he knows that his end is gonna
be a violent very violent it's not gonna
be a fun end because if he gets
convicted Oh we'll have a murder yeah
and they'll put them in where they put
the rats you know when people ran out
this protective custody but guess what
don't kill you in protective custody
protective custody
oh yeah use nothing what's that [ __ ]
that OJ's wife had a restraining on yeah
what people have died with restraining
orders then die with oh my friend told
me he was like yeah you can get PC we
got guys easy you're done yeah take a
giant matter of time they got guys on
their team on their team that will
request PC just to go get on that kill
you hey there's tons of stories of
people who have done you wrongly and
have gone to prison and we could get
them once they're in prison we know
where they are and there's somebody
who's got 80 years and their wife needs
2000 to pay the mortgage oh yeah I'll
slice them up into pieces there's four
it's [ __ ] he's gonna give the wife 25
wanted to pay her mortgage and watch
watched on the news they take as he is
they take everything his eyeballs that
by the time the cops get there there's
nothing the blood to donate
yeah he does nothing left to donate they
take
his nose you know that's the that's why
when you see all these people get in
trouble and they get these cops that get
convicted whatever they did wrong but
when they go and that guy is number one
on the poster
Public Enemies gonna buy the song but
the cop that killed George Floyd
so what what name me one prison where
there's not one one black prison guard
right and there's gonna be three good
white cops and they gonna go guess who's
here yeah he disgrace cops so he knows
he might as well hang himself now like
to make it yeah he's not gonna make it
he's not gonna make it he might as well
kill him he said it comes up he's
avoiding getting raped stabbed isn't he
had a real rat face on him yeah they're
gonna rape him they're gonna do a bunch
of things to him he might as well tell
his family just to kill him on
visitation his wife left him right after
it and yeah he's to kiss a debt that's
why they got him on suicide watch but
those guys do not last I don't care how
they go away they're sending them but
when you have a hundred and twenty years
sentence you ain't going nowhere
yeah and they've already exhausted your
appeal and you appeal three times you're
not going nowhere but guess what you got
a wife and two kids at home and they
need money so it's quick it's like a
quick deal
it's like code over the phone and they
were you write a letter till he burns it
and he's on a mission from st. you get
the money is and usually you give the
money when the job is done I'll bring it
to your wife right now just to give you
a little bit more incentive to let you
know the guy you're dealing with and
that's over I don't I did time I heard
some horrific stories and how guys were
making a living inside inside contracts
they happen all the inside so like a far
insider of his night man that's a
complete different business that's why
you don't that's why nobody there's
nothing you don't worry about nothing
he's gonna go to jail we get him he's
gonna go to Pelican Bay and we're gonna
make the call wherever he goes wherever
he goes we're gonna make a call no set
oh my god got a friend that's got a
friend PC they'll just set you on fire
in yourself yeah
it's about very scary I did a couple
[ __ ] months and you know I felt
comfortable after a while but I knew
where I was you don't turn the lights
off you never turn the lights off you
know where you are and you know anything
could bounce off in any [ __ ] time
it's that quick you're dealing with 90
people who have [ __ ] tempest ten of
them are nice people who did bad things
but there's 80 killers who they got
nothing to lose
they don't care by the time you get to
some levels like when I went to Ordway
for a couple nights and before I went to
Camp George West that's that's there's a
prison in Colorado they called gladiator
heaven that's where they send all the
steroid people but at 21 to 26 then what
the fight themselves to death die
probably send you they call 18 to 25
they call those places gladiator that do
you all make it you won't make it those
are for young kids and then you move on
and once you get older you're peaceful
but there's always one [ __ ] that
he wants you and you have to establish
yourself well that's good that you took
care of them bro I appreciate you you've
been good that was my diligence a lot of
people I'm sorry he passed on Yin [ __ ]
that's one thing you have good great
karma bro you don't a lot of people a
lot of my friends say you help them all
the time than me that's why I check in
on it I'm the same as you we will look
out for people and look out for people
or empathetic guys and we've seen some
[ __ ] in our lives so we understand how
bad it can get you understand I
understand the plight I understand I've
been there yeah I've covered every
emotion that people who listen to this
show covet I've had a loss I've been
addicted I've been homeless
you know I've struggled you know I've
been that you know it's every situation
you wanted a bit more broken I've had a
kid taken from me I lost a kid on
purpose because I was a junkie I mean
tell me I've been through all the
emotions you go yeah and this is what
I've always stress at that set
just because you guys think we're living
out here we put up and sound one leg at
a time
mm-hmm just like regular people we've
all had [ __ ] crazy past you know I
tell Lee all the time go out there have
a story go gonna be deep do something go
get crabs you just can't sit me out
you're 31 you don't want to die not
having something that's what it's all
about is meeting the chick who says to
you
let's go to my friend's house and you're
like okay and also listen orgy and
there's a white chick getting [ __ ] by
eight black guys in the ass and they're
all coming on the face and you said no
way I and that's at Boston oh that's
where you think you're uncomfortable you
have to go somewhere where you become
uncomfortable to really go home and go
wow I never want to do that again like
it's it's just being uncomfortable
places yeah you need you need to see the
bad in order to appreciate the good I
guess I I don't mind seeing the bad I
don't really want to go to you don't
have to be a part of the bed yeah
the manslaughter and doing doing crap
there's levels you don't have to go to
that level you're not the guy that
they're gonna be letting in anyway so
you got all these weeks going on brother
I'm [ __ ] back on the road just
working I'm happy for you I had written
I had an entirely new actor before this
whole should happen digit and I was like
ready I was it was ready and I was on
the road working it and I was like I
write I'm pilot I was in the polishing
stage you know and it was about to all
start in June and then then this should
happen and then I forgot it all cuz I
don't write it down then I got on stage
Thursday last week where josh says last
week american comedy club you went all
the way down I did seven shows seven
show first and I couldn't remember my
name
second night oh it all came back how did
you feel on stage after the first night
I thought I was acting to be honest with
you
ten minutes in I wanted to get the [ __ ]
off stage why I saw it's uncomfortable I
was like I can't remember anything how
do you mean oh I'm doing so is that my
head wasn't in it yeah the wall sold out
but I mean it's a hundred capacity and I
mean so but that's it's all good now
and what nights did you do Thursday
Friday Saturday Sunday one Thursday to
Friday to Saturday to Sunday yeah I need
to start one just one show I think the
first shows and be enough uncle Joey the
first show yeah you're gonna feel it the
first show but I will you will first
show you'll be like calm focus there's
little things you may were you forget
and then like what I don't know like
little details about something I mean oh
you're at though yeah yeah yeah I don't
have a knack now yeah
there's no I that's why part of me is
happy that they cancelled break yeah
give you a break give you a break
because no I'm going back to do
residential whatever the [ __ ] oh yeah
once a month twice a month in Brea and
once an ox nine because I'll tell you
afterwards it's just a lot better for me
mm-hm it'll give you an hour to work I
can have an hour work it's the pieces of
15 minutes my I think at this stage
right now if what I'm looking to do
that's the best thing I could do yeah
I'm gonna go on next year once the
soprano movie comes out this is it done
it's done but they put an ax push
everything back you're in it no my
friends in it yeah I'm [ __ ] in it
the prequel unless they [ __ ] cut Mike
in it is that why they were on that Jose
thing Mike and Steve daughter little dad
doing a really good podcast called the
soprano podcast I know I don't know the
name of it it's something and you know
Michael had the he wrote the script or
the screenplay to omerta and he never
made it this was like 29 I didn't when
he was like maybe 1718 years ago he told
me this he had he was working on that
Michael Perry oh yeah yeah writer he's a
great guy though is he great little
peaked up here close to you yeah is it
by me I lost touch with him I lost touch
with him but yeah we used to hang out
when he was shooting we did a movie
together in Toronto years ago whenever
hangul actor - he's a real [ __ ] really
serious [ __ ] and that good actor Jesus
you could see him on Rogen he was a
little like he was out of his realm
he's an introverted guy well sure if I
used to be the Booker for the Riviera
right
a very very reserved he's great at what
he does he directed a few Epsilon O's he
wrote a few episodes of The Sopranos so
he really has it together he's uh
together young kid together
he's not just spider who got shot by a
spider yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] EO [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah we were at a bar in
Toronto and like most Ben 2002 and we're
having some drinks and this Indian dude
comes up he's like oh [ __ ] Russell
Peters and goes oh man he points a
Michael and it's like that's amazing you
do all you and do all the Indian actors
and comedians know each other and I'm
like huh and he goes to Michael Oher
party Andy are you from and Michael goes
Calcutta [ __ ] hilarious
no he was good yet that was a good
podcast they listened to Sopranos man is
a great show that not a lot of people
watched did you what they were saying
that it's number two on HBO behind
Westwood right now yeah that hasn't been
on the air for 13-year old you know the
wire was apparently like a flop for the
first three years but it's the fun one
of the best shows ever made I'm thinking
about putting it on again oh no it's
more than that egg was six really Wow
this two shows I'm dying to put back on
again the wire and the prism one from
HBO ah ah yeah yeah I heard that one in
ten times I had to I see single abuzz
they say ours was like Sex in the City
for guys yeah oz is oz was good I don't
know and I just about the about a month
ago I go in power I like power that's
the guy that went to that was 50 cent
show
oh no other boys throws on stars that
was a [ __ ] I loved it'll ha I like
they say that Harlem show was good the
kingdom yeah I gotta watch that that's
one with Forest Whitaker it's your for
the other side dude no the other but
Godfather of Harlem to Godfather Harlem
it's the other black it's not forced
with her no it's a guy from a 8 mile
the big black guy from 8 mile that's
biggie is also on oh you're talking
about Omar
Benson Miller entourage for football
what's on OK and that ballers Wallace
you know Marv Benson Miller he plays the
Miami Dolphins guy yeah no I think it's
uh yeah I think that's what no no no
it's Forrest Whitaker and it's funny
because everybody thinks Omar is Forest
Whitaker's kid yeah it's [ __ ] crazy I
can't see without my glasses no no I've
seen the [ __ ] billboard that's all I
know
was it called Godfather armed his
[ __ ] son tan and there's no burn you
bro I rip off my wife says she's been
sweeping my skin for the last four days
it hurts doesn't hurt anymore
to stop her after five days it's just a
burn was so [ __ ] deep I burnt
yeah it's Forest Whitaker Forest
Whitaker that's a great show - yeah I'm
gonna see if I can't believe you love
all that stuff I love you for that you
love music
you're still spinning at night still
spin when I got time downstairs the kids
danced why yeah no no my house is that
it's in a whole nother wing you won't
even hear it really yeah so the spinning
is somewhere else in the man cave so but
you gonna play for your kids I mean my
kid well the problem is when the kids
see it they're like they want to go I
want to DJ and then they want to just
hit buttons and not and it bothers me
Mike listen you respect the art or
overcome push the buttons you scratch
and stuff yeah it's the battle no [ __ ]
yeah Russell you're an interesting
[ __ ] man it never ends with you
you Joseph how dare you every week is a
new [ __ ] adventure yeah so Miami's
ready for you you shouldn't I gotta
close that city by the time you can hope
not I'm looking forward to it you know I
used you trust everything but I had a
chick to blow off my dick there once did
you in Miami
yeah if somebody's gonna do blow off
your dick it's gonna be my hair it was a
small that's what I do don't we this is
what can the things in the world I had a
chick who told me in Miami one night if
I could do a headstand I could [ __ ] and
you should have seen me try to do a
headstand coked-up I try like two times
she got up and left
No you think I'm [ __ ] getting it so
it's anything is possible in Miami kill
him next week I love you to death what's
your website anything Russell Peters
calm that Russell at Russell Peters on
Instagram you got a full schedule North
Carolina Raleigh Raleigh Indianapolis
helium you going everywhere that's gotta
go man
well I wish you luck I thank you for
coming on the show on a Mondays for
having me you know been talking about it
for months
yeah we're gonna zoom it we were gonna
face masks and I like Joey I don't give
a [ __ ] let's just do it a virus into it
the door want to see you I want to see
it always open I got [ __ ] slice off
Clorox
I spray some of him everybody gets to
[ __ ] it the lights off
just so I take that bugs back home with
them I love your [ __ ] hold on
one second let me read some ads dear
[Applause]
[Music]
we're back like Ovid no big [ __ ] deal
you didn't knock over lose making a
comeback get it together a bunch of
[ __ ] mooks walking around jumping up
and down hugging each other will he
expect anyway I hope you enjoyed the
Russell Peters [ __ ] a little
interview I love Russell he's a good man
solid we did a nighttime one just think
you know what comics man and I came to
the solution that we were gonna see we
used to do the show at night and all of
a sudden we became [ __ ] and we
started doing it at 9:00 in the morning
like little [ __ ] [ __ ] that we are
and we got to go back to nights because
we got to fill all nights we just sit
there and every time jeopardy comes on I
want to pull the [ __ ] knife in my
throat so thank you Russell again for
coming listen I got some dates for you
protesters and want to come out with
sticks and [ __ ] come on down the more
users that come down the more [ __ ]
tickets I sell so keep it up [ __ ]
anyway I got July 30th through August
1st at the Brea improv we should be open
I know a lot of you guys bought tickets
you know I never wanted to [ __ ] none of
you guys and [ __ ] whatever so we're
coming Plus on top of that I'm gonna be
doing a house of residency they're two
Tuesday's a month and one Wednesday and
one that I want - is there a month up in
Oxnard I'll keep you guys posted again
thank you very much for having me it's
Wednesday the 24th my anniversary is
next weekend I appreciate all the
support and love you gave me 20 years
with the same woman I couldn't [ __ ]
and stay with the same woman for 20
minutes she got out of my face once I
hit it with a shot of bad breath but
listen this one's stuck around we're
here we're queer you know I'm saying I
want to shout out everybody who had my
back I love you [ __ ] to death
if you're not [ __ ] loyal and you know
I have no friends you have nothing in
life you guys proved that last week so I
love you to death
thank you for having my back I think the
[ __ ] for helping me I'm being a
soldier of debt and listen we're gonna
keep telling stories okay nothing's
gonna [ __ ] change next week I'm gonna
tell you about when I poke the guy in
the eye and he we got a [ __ ] he
walked around with a bad news for three
weeks and he couldn't go to the cops I
tell you that one that's a good one have
a great weekend
bless you stay black oh I got a little
surprise for you tomorrow Thursday
you're here by the Friday all right so
you guys know something's coming I'm
just giving you a heads-up because I
love you I can't say whether this but
you [ __ ] know one of this
already
don't forget look on your computer
Friday morning stay black have a great
week I love you [ __ ] kick this
melee
[Applause]
[Music]